barbara 22 ans est apprenti depuis
septembre dernier veut partager son
expérience
actuellement en formation dans une
entreprise de sidérurgie cette ville
prose yen s'est inscrite pour les
rencontres de l'apprentissage à la
maison de l'étudiant de lui en cours
pendant la journée l'étudiante a
présenté son parcours
la question qui vont me revenir ça va
être surtout sur comment se passe la
pente hissage si au sein de mon
entreprise ça se passe bien
l'intégration des apprentis au sein des
services
ce que la l'intégration des apprentis
est très importante c'est souvent ce
qu'on voit de plus en arrivant comme
barbara ils sont des dizaines
d'apprentis et s'être déplacé ce
mercredi 26 avril pour cette première
édition où mon souhait c'est ça c'est
vraiment que des apprentis puissent
témoigner expliquer quelle est leur
quotidien pour donner envie à d'autres
jeunes effectivement de les rejoindre et
de devenir apprenti je suis rémunéré je
suis prise au sérieux dans l'entreprise
il est plus dans la même posture qu'un
élève le classique quoi il est devenu
vraiment salariés donc c'est vrai que
c'est autrement plus importants plus
plus plus parlant
les apprentis accompagné des
responsables ont présenté cette occasion
les métiers accessibles à tous les
niveaux de formation du ca paix avec +5
sur une vingtaine de stands un vrai plus
pour les 200 étudiants présents trouve
ça toujours enrichissant d'apprendre ce
que les autres peuvent faire et leur
façon de voir les choses donner des
conseils
oui oui un petit peu mais après c'est
plutôt des échanges de points de vue en
tout cas vu le succès rencontré cette
année une deuxième édition devrait être
programmé d'après les chiffres de
l'éducation nationale 7 jeunes sur 10
trouvent à l'emploi la sortie de
l'apprentissage